[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show so
some of you may remember that at some
point in the last six months at this
point it all kind of blends together Joe
Biden said he was going to pick a woman
to be his running mate
do you remember Pat when it was or what
the context was I know he said it I
don't know when he suggested it early on
in the campaign cycle but I think he
made it official when he was debating
Bernie Sanders one-on-one in that last
Democratic primary debate right and the
media ran with that story and I think
that was the big takeaway from that
debate so now given that Joe Biden has
already said he will be picking a woman
because of what's going on with the
protests and with George Floyd etc he is
being urged to pick a black vice
president and of course if you say well
it's got to be a woman and she's got to
be black the obvious frontrunner is
Kamala Harris Stacey Abrams is also
being discussed although I don't think
it's likely at all that Biden picks are
I would be shocked if Biden picked
Stacey Abrams but the problem with
Kamala Harris is when you look at the
the cause of the protests Kamala Harris
is record as Attorney General of
California is widely seen as being on
the wrong side when it comes to law
enforcement and street crime and
minorities so it seems like Biden is
being pushed into an untenable box by
some of the demands well I've always
been skeptical that he would pick Kamala
Harris because of course she owned him
on the debate stage maybe you wouldn't
be such a good look if he chooses her as
VP yeah I suppose Stacy aprons would be
a possibility I'm thinking about the
progressive black women out there like
maybe Nina Turner or Jana Presley who is
our representative here in Boston I just
don't think that I don't think so I
don't think so I mean Nina Turner was
she was a was it a state senator in Ohio
I believe so and of course one of
Bernie's campaign managers or co-chairs
coach yes I'm kind of yeah I don't know
so the the other thing that has to be
mentioned here in the context of all of
this is that we learned a couple of
weeks ago that Amy Klobuchar
char senator from Minnesota was being
vetted and then we learned that Derrick
shavon the officer who killed George
Floyd was previously not prosecuted
thanks to Amy Klobuchar 'z decision and
in my mind that instantly ended Amy
Klobuchar ours shot at being the VP
yeah I thought Amy Klobuchar was the
front-runner and I thought maybe she was
offered a VP slot in exchange for
getting out back in February she would
have been a good pick I think maybe you
know from the Midwest you seem like a
likable person of course Biden wanted to
choose a woman so if she fit that that
box too I thought she was going to be
the front-runner but it seems like now
with everything that's going on he may
have to choose someone else although I
mean it's sad to say but you know he'll
probably choose the VP and another month
or two will this still be the top story
going on will there still be protests
will there still be the outrage that we
see right now you know that that's a
good question and it's so listen if
January 15th
you had said by May 15th we will have
lost 25 percent of the workforce I think
almost no one would have believed it if
on April 15 you had said on June 2nd the
country will be embroiled in the most
the highest degree of civil unrest we've
seen in a long time and Trump will be
saying that he is going to send the
military to States to be even tougher I
think very few people would have
believed it so it's hard to imagine that
we know what the situation is going to
be in two months I think you're right
about that yeah it's the same reason why
we don't want to get overconfident about
buying it even though things look pretty
good right now Biden sitting at about 53
percent favorability whereas Trump is
underwater that could change that could
change very very quickly and we have
seen an underdog win in a presidential
election before so can't be
overconfident I still am leaning towards
it might be Warren that's the best pick
overall and you know I spoke to ROH
Khanna about it last week the
conventional wisdoms of Biden's of
Delaware senator and former VP Warren is
a Massachusetts senator that doesn't
seem like it's going to do well in a lot
of parts of the country I don't know
that it will really hurt Biden in the
places that might be the
difference-maker is like Michigan or
Wisconsin and she is certainly the most
of the people that are in the running
Warren's more progressive than Harris
warns more progressive than clos Bashar
I know you know you can talk about Nina
Turner another I don't think they really
are in the running
maybe Warren is the way to go yeah I
talked about this a couple weeks ago on
my Friday bonus show that uh you know we
know a lot of progressives aren't very
happy with Elizabeth Warren right now
because they felt as though she should
have dropped out of the race and
endorsed Bernie Sanders when he still
had a chance and I get all that I just
feel like among the candidates that
Biden could reasonably consider as VP I
think it's pretty clear that Warren
would be the most progressive out of all
of them and for that reason in that
reason alone that's why I want her to be
the VP also and finance an old guy you
would be like 82 if he decides to run
for re-election there's a good chance
that he doesn't run for reelection and
it just wants to be a one-term president
it would be great to have Elizabeth
Warren be the VP because then she would
be seen as maybe a presumptive nominee
in 2024 and then we can get a
progressive in the White House certainly
conceivable certainly conceive oh by the
way Pat there's like a squeaking car is
your chair squeaky today
yeah I'm shaking a little bit I don't
know what kind of chair is it that you
use anyway is it like a schoolboy chair
as we would consider it like a like a
desk chair that rocks a little bit but
not because it's supposed to because
it's broken in the bottom oh geez oh we
got to get me a new chair yeah we gotta
expand that early okay
Facebook employees are increasingly I
don't know that irate is to to to a
bridge too far if Facebook employees are
not pleased with a CEO Mark Zuckerberg
decision not to take action on a bunch
of controversial posts by Donald Trump
from last week now of course on one hand
we saw Twitter flagged some of trumps
post as inciting violence and you have
to click that you're sure you want to
see it it's sensitive content
Mark Zuckerberg has said yeah we're not
going to do that and now a bunch of
Facebook employees set up a virtual walk
out everybody's working from home but
they said we're going to take the day
off of work managers were told not to
retaliate that would also look pretty
bad if they ended up retaliating and
they said don't make the employees use
paid time off in order
for the protest to happen you know I I
don't really know what's going on with
Mark Zuckerberg I know that there's a
lot of hot takes where people say he's
essentially a trumpet I don't think that
that's the case at all
there's others who continue to say this
is just a ruse because Zuckerberg is a
leftist shill and he's doing this in
order to get credibility for when he
then does stuff with Facebook to deny
Trump re-election I I think that what's
going on is that Mark Zuckerberg is
finding himself in a difficult position
for him now listen he's a
multi-billionaire oh what a difficult
position okay I get it he's totally
privileged and and he doesn't have
financial concerns but I think he's in a
position where he is trying to thread a
needle that is very difficult to thread
not to avoid angering anybody on a
political basis but more to not become
too much the center of attention when it
comes to the regulation of social media
I think Zuckerberg priority has
basically been we want to self-regulate
he went and talked to you know
committees in the house maybe the Senate
as well I think but yeah both he said I
remember him saying senator to some
people and he has argued listen you know
we want sensible regulation and we can
decide what the regulation would be you
know will regulate ourselves sort of
stuff and I think his priority is not to
do much one way or the other to not piss
off the side that is more likely to
bring down the hammer on him I think
that's all that this is I don't think
it's really about political bias yeah I
think it's more about business and about
politics and he can look like maybe a
neutral objective arbiter if he's the
one operating a social media platform
that doesn't censor people that truly is
a platform where everyone can just voice
their opinion and then that's it there's
no censorship there's no sort of
political bias that maybe other sites
are accused of and it is pretty clear
that he doesn't want to face the
backlash that a Trump is throwing at
Twitter because they're deciding to
censor his tweets and that's why he got
on the phone with Trump soon after that
and made sure to say the Trump we're not
going to do this here at Facebook now
yeah I mean it is just to interject
briefly the truth is Facebook already
has this thing where they label certain
sources untrust where
the the truth is that the fake news is
disproportionately on the right I'm not
saying there isn't left-wing fake news
but if you think back to the 2016
election
there was no major left-wing fake news
narrative on the right you had Hillary's
email nonsense you had pizza gate you
had you know Benghazi stuff you had Emmy
I'm now I don't have a list in front of
me now but the point is by by doing
things right facebook is likely going to
label more right-wing news outlets than
left-wing news outlets as fake or
questionable so they're already kind of
making these choices and now Zuckerberg
says well when it comes to Trump we're
not gonna do it we're not gonna flag his
messages yeah that's the risk that's the
same problem that CNN and these other
mainstream media outlets deal with like
sometimes the objective truth favors one
side or another typically it's the left
when it comes to fake news and
especially you know these other policy
issues it's typically the left that's
right on the policy but the media has to
have this neutrality bias because they
don't want to piss off the right-wing
that's exactly the role that Mark
Zuckerberg is playing here I just wonder
to like finish up on the point I was
making before does is it really a good
business decision to stay neutral and to
try to you know not censor too much and
remain a platform if all of your
employees are against the decision if
most of your employees come from
California and there's the maybe you
know social justice types and they want
to see Trump not get away with
inflammatory speech and all that stuff
at a certain point if the walkouts
continue and if people aren't willing to
work for your company then it's no
longer good businesses you know I think
most of the employees are not really
going to walk away permanently I think
most are relatively happy with their
compensation and the work culture so I
don't think that that's the real threat
and and you know what it may be the
right business decision in the sense
that advertisers are going to keep
advertising on Facebook mostly if long
as Facebook doesn't do anything outrages
and I think simply inaction on Trump's
messages is not over the line for most
advertisers if advertisers can spend a
hundred bucks and make a hundred and
twenty by buying ads on Facebook they're
gonna keep spending money and that's
ultimately what Facebook relies on do
you think conservatives will try to make
their own outlet their own Facebook and
their own Twitter because it seems like
the other efforts that we
Sene trying to make these new social
media platforms that are basically just
carbon copies of what we already have
that you ever seem to work I would love
it if they did and maybe it would if it
was even remotely successful maybe it
would pull some of the lunatics off of
Twitter and I wouldn't have to mute
10,000 people the way you know I have
muted right now let's talk about one of
the effects of the civil unrest that
we've been seeing in Alabama protesters
targeted a hundred and fifteen year old
Confederate soldiers and sailors a
sailors monument in Lynn Park Alabama
and Lynn Park which I believe is in
Birmingham Alabama they defaced it they
chipped away at its base and the mayor
now says we are going to remove it a
large crane arrived I believe it was
yesterday shortly before 8:00 p.m. and
they pulled it down and this has
actually been a fight for a long time
and there were elements that wanted this
removed and there were elements that
said it's a part of history and it
should stay but you know we talked about
are there any actual
outcomes to the protests that we are
seeing I mentioned already I don't think
Chris Wallace spends an hour on Fox News
Sunday with Cornel West and talking
about coronavirus effecting minorities
if it's not for what's going on I don't
know that this statue gets removed this
quickly if that now again this is not an
endorsement of any particular tactic but
to argue that these have had zero effect
is probably not accurate at this point
yeah I totally agree you could say it's
had a mixed effect you could even maybe
try to argue that this will have a
negative consequence altogether because
the protests and the riots will just
make it so that people are more
distressing of one another and I can
turn the country against each other you
can make all those arguments but
certainly there will be some good that
comes out of this and Confederate
statues coming down maybe one of those
things and it makes me think like I mean
I'm typically against tagging and
graffiti and you know property damage it
depends on the reasoning of course but
am I really against someone
spray-painting a Confederate statue
something that I don't think should be
standing there in the first place and
it's a I mean that's targeting a
government property it's not targeting
anyone's like local business or anything
does that play a role in that I don't
think any of anything at like a moral
level against spray-painting the the
monuments and trying to get them
yeah I mean it's like okay let's go with
an extreme example let's say some place
was so misguided that they had a Hitler
statue is anyone really gonna be upset
about spray painting and defacing a
Hitler statue particularly if it
accelerates the Hitler statue being
taken down it's pretty tough to get
against being too worked up about that
so okay it's a Confederate statue it's
not Hitler but certainly the Confederacy
was fighting for states rights to keep
having slaves as we often like to say
there are people who like to say well
it's a historical you know that there
was these were Americans this was the
Confederacy and they were Americans and
it was it was a war it's very hard for
me to be too broken up about it now of
course the problem is we can't just say
any civil unrest that is widespread is
not going to be limited only to defacing
Confederate statues that's the reality
as well and that's what that's like more
of a practical reality than a political
one right of course you can bring up the
slippery slope argument which is what if
someone decides to spray paint a George
Washington or a Thomas Jefferson statue
would that be okay okay let's decide
because the own slaves and of course I
think it's an interesting conversation
to have I think with the competitive
statues though it does go to show that
this tactic can be effective because I'm
sure they've probably tried to petition
the government I'm sure they try to
reach out to local officials and hold
protests if not about this Confederate
statue in particular about other ones
we've seen that all across the country
and so many of them are still up there
still standing right now so if you have
actually people who are willing to tear
them down at themselves and then
spray-paint them and get it to a point
where it's a risk to even have that
monument there because it attracts
protesters and it's risks to public
safety and public health and all that
maybe that is the move maybe that is the
right thing to do and we could be seeing
it before our very eyes last thing just
like a disclaimer I think Pat and I both
realize Confederate statues are not the
most important thing going on right now
and we have much bigger problems to
solve and whether the statues stay up or
come down it doesn't fix the broader
issues we're dealing with but it's an
interesting discussion and one that has
been the subject of a lot of different
articles over the last 24 hours so I
think it is worth worth spitballing at
some
ideas about that's going to do it for
today I hope you'll join us tomorrow
we've got a new show and the new bonus
show both are coming up tomorrow the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]